[Music]
who's Charles Moulton that is my
pseudonym
why don't you write Wonder Woman under
your real name because most Americans
have a low opinion of comic book writers
or that's something else the person is
most happy when they are submissive to
loving Authority I want to study earth
she'll break your heart don't be jealous
I'm your wife no you're jinglun i think
you long for an unconventional life
maybe I just want her because you do
you think it's possible to love two
people at the same time why not
what is normal it can never happen
the world work that it
[Music]
the world can't stop us is this what you
really want dr. Marston every issue of
Wonder Woman is filled with violence
torture and sadomasochism this abnormal
behavior and their comic is reckless a
woman must not be told how to use her
freedom she must find out for herself
if you'd want to understand the mind of
a woman you can start with that you are
brilliant pure of heart
hilarious ferocious you fart my life
when a woman has a secret identity why
is that she has to hide her true self
from a man's poem
what would happen if Wonder Woman's
secret identity was revealed everything
would be awesome
I wonder if you were the one with a
secret identity
[Music]
you